although we tend to think about
christopher columbus's first voyage in
transforming the history of the americas
it actually transformed a great deal
more than that and in this video i want
to talk about the larger world
historical process that columbus's
voyage opened up that transformed not
only the americas but also europe and
africa
and this was called the colombian
exchange
so what was the colombian exchange
this is a process
of
transferring
[Music]
plants
animals
microbes
and people
across the atlantic in both directions
and not just trading these goods but
transplanting them from europe and
africa into the americas and the other
way around and some of these exchanges
of species were intentional like
bringing new crops to grow in
environments that were suited to them
and some of them were unintentional like
the microbes and pests which were like
little hitchhikers on the bodies and
crops that europeans brought to the new
world and it had
a tremendous environmental effect
that had
real
consequences
for people on both sides of the atlantic
so let's look a little bit closer at
some of the things that were exchanged
across the atlantic after columbus began
the process of bringing things from the
old world to the new world and from the
new world to the old world so first
let's take a closer look at the plants
now spain much like portugal was hoping
to use this tropical landscape to grow
cash crops and so columbus brought with
him sugar
and grapes for wine and coffee these
were all crops that would fetch high
prices in europe it was so lucrative to
grow sugar
in the caribbean that they didn't even
want to give up any space to grow food
they imported their food so that they
could spend all of their land growing
sugar the europeans also brought new
world crops back to the old world and
some of these it's almost impossible to
imagine a world before for example the
tomato had ever come to europe can you
imagine italian food with no tomato
sauce they also brought corn and
potatoes and sweet potatoes and cassava
or manioc
and what's important about most of these
crops is that they're very calorically
dense
so
if you grew a field of potatoes instead
of a field of wheat which might be a
typical crop grown in the old world
before contact you can feed
three times as many people with a field
of potatoes
than you can with wheat so what does
this cause it causes a real increase in
population in europe
it also causes an increase in population
in africa where manioc is a crop that
was frequently grown and also very
calorically dense so new world foods
helped europe and africa increase their
populations
so what about these animals the
europeans brought cattle
sheep
pigs and horses
to the new world with mixed results
horses for example
were a tremendous technology that was
widely adopted throughout mexico and the
native americans living in the great
plains of what is today the united
states found that horses revolutionized
their ability to hunt so that was a
great step up for them the pigs they
brought over however weren't so great
because europeans allowed the pigs to
roam freely which meant that they ate
everything including the native
americans crops
and they multiplied very quickly so they
became kind of a pest in the new world
probably the thing that had the biggest
effect in the colombian exchange was the
transfer of old-world diseases to the
new world so with europeans came
smallpox measles
whooping cough and the native americans
had
very little immunity to these diseases
it's estimated that within 100 years
of columbus landing in hispaniola
of all people who were living in the
americas
died of disease
this is a demographic catastrophe the
likes of which the world has never seen
before or
since
and most of the native americans who
were affected by these diseases would
never have actually inter interacted
with a european they just
had trade networks
that spread these diseases back and
forth
throughout the americas
now you might be wondering
okay so if the native americans were
being exposed to new diseases from the
europeans weren't the europeans also
native americans why didn't it have such
a strong impact on them there are a
couple of reasons for that one is that
there
was a greater population density
in europe and africa
there were more people and they lived
closer together in cities
and so this gave diseases opportunities
to bounce back and forth between people
and evolve and become stronger the other
important thing is that
europeans
lived close to animals
and as we remember from things like bird
flu or swine flu animals and humans can
pass diseases back and forth between
each other and that makes those diseases
even stronger in comparison native
americans didn't have much population
density and they only domesticated dogs
and dogs unlike pigs can't pass that
many diseases back and forth between
humans so native americans just didn't
have diseases that were as vicious as
the diseases that had been passed from
person to person for many thousands of
years in europe and africa so this gets
to the last aspect of the colombian
exchange the exchange of people so very
quickly after europeans arrived
the native american population suffered
from a tremendous
outbreak of disease
which meant that although the europeans
had hoped to enslave them and use them
as a labor force in these caribbean
plantations very few of them survive
which meant that the europeans needed
another labor force they found that
labor source on the west coast of africa
where there was a long tradition of
slave trading
and they brought enslaved african people
against their will across the atlantic
to work in the caribbean so that very
quickly a majority of the population
in the caribbean
was of african descent
ironically this population explosion
brought on by new world foods meant that
there were more people in africa who
were possible subjects to enslavement
and it helped them keep their population
numbers relatively steady despite the
exodus
of as many as
12 to 13 million people over the course
of the years between columbus arriving
and approximately 1800.
likewise this population explosion in
europe led to worries about
overpopulation
in
the 1600s and 1700s and what did the
nations of europe do they began sending
people over to the colonies so the
contact and exchange initiated by
christopher columbus when he connected
the old world with the new had a
profound effect on the environment not
just of the new world but of the old
world as well and this profound effect
on the whole benefited europe at the
expense of the americas and of africa